[Music]
is that gonna fit everyone
easily 12 customers total how do they
turn a profit 12.50 ahead that's how
what are we eating a rolex
it's one of his
classics you have to try the mouse feel
of the mignonette please don't say
mouthful tonight will be madness
welcome
we'll endeavor to make your evening as
pleasant as possible
[Music]
welcome to hawthorne
here we are family
we harvest we ferment
we jowl
[Music]
we gel
he's not just a chef he's a storyteller
the game is trying to guess what the
overarching theme of the entire meal is
going to be
you won't know until the end who are you
i
am margo
how do you care i have to know if you're
with us
or with them
this menu the pictures they're of us
this guest list
how do they get these it's not good
this entire evening
jesus christ this is just theater it's
stage crowd we're leaving now
has been painstakingly
planned this is real isn't it
what the hell is going on
we now offer you a 45 second head start
okay 45 seconds starts now
this is what you're paying for
get out of my way
it's all part of the menu
it's okay no we're gonna die tonight
[Music]
happy birthday to
you
you told him it was my birthday
seemed funny about three hours ago
you